[Musique]
15000 km et 10 pays depuis un an
guillaume et kevin taurins sont sur les
routes les chemins les deux frères
yvelinois ont quitté la capitale le 26
mai 2018 et la france dit que c'est
passé vite et en même temps s'est passé
super lentement ce qui s'est passé des
milliards et des milliards de choses on
a fait beaucoup de rencontres
on a parcouru énormément de km il ya eu
beaucoup de péripéties des bonnes comme
des mauvaises donc c'est vrai que c'est
une année très très riche dans votre
petite vie des péripéties malheureuse
comme le vol d'un vélo celui de
guillaume à lisbonne après seulement
3000 km de voyage mais aussi des
aventures inédites comme la traversée de
l'atlantique en bateau et des rencontres
qui chamboule leur programme on
s'organise plus de la même manière on
prévoit plus sur six mois mais vraiment
déjà si on sait se montrer dans un mois
c'est c'est bien c'est ce qui est dur à
prendre en compte c'est la météo
et puis aussi les rencontres qu'on fait
sont par moments très très forte et qui
nous oblige à rester
enfin on se sent obligé de rester un peu
avec les personnes qu'aux rencontres
comme cette halte en argentine trois
semaines dans un village la grita avec
la rencontre d'un français michel et
voyez à faire tous les lacs là comme ça
on descendait cela il ya l'euro comme
volkan dany l'a vu en photo et à partir
de là tout est extraordinaire un voyage
penser à 2 mais rarement réalisé en duo
parfois rejoints par famille et annie il
roule aussi régulièrement avec d'autres
cyclistes depuis rio nous sommes trois
nous sommes accompagnés de denis qui
avait fait 5 jours avec nous en partant
de paris donc le 26 mai dernier
on a aussi été accompagnés par un
brésilien qui a fait une journée toute
entière avec nous on a voyagé assise
pendant un mois
c'étaient tous des tourdumondiste tous
français notamment un qui vient de saint
germain est un breton et beaucoup de
bretons sur la route dans un an les deux
frères espèrent être ou non des
amériques leur voyage doit encore durer
deux ans
et ça continue